welcome to this video playing a creep
really wow I'm screwing this up equity
Brian equally brine something like that
it's another lens right yeah and what is
he doing playing the four nights here
that's not a very exciting opening you
don't see that happen too often notice
it is reasonably high ready and this is
just a bad opening so let's see is it
Queen g5 or queen t5i keep Quinn g5
right
now Bishop h3 or how was it exactly
playdough 86 I keep forgetting those
things yeah I think it's probably a 6
surprising to get this on the board
against a pretty high rated player and
it's not an not a provisional rating or
something okay um yeah so here i go
bishop age 3 immediately why not netting
the exchange so takes takes takes yeah
let's check let's take that who said
that greed is good go on gecko in Wall
Street I don't know in chess sometimes
greed is good be five or not probably be
five still grid is one of the seven
deadly sins yeah but I guess in chess
it's okay if you don't get punished
immediately you should take stuff okay
this runs into a check so let's take
away the e5 square and then go King d7
the position is still a little bit on
let's say I don't know how to call it a
little bit messy let's say because of
the somewhat irregular pawn structure
and my rooks being a little bit um yeah
a little bit dominated by this annoyed I
wouldn't mind to check on c6 sometime
see going to see five maybe
can take this right
yeah I really have a number of pawns
already ok I'm giving this back it's
really ok I Jack a ton of extra points
and the night really was a complete
nuisance
how many points added to just two white
felt like more retakes I go f form
three connected passed pawns
so it's going for rookie aid well that
that isn't really good technical play
what I played here but I think it still
still is okay g-53 check and then I t1b
to write check yeah i know i can go back
and play I cannot really go back wanted
to play would be to maybe you look age
84 look on the second
okay come on let's do let's think about
this for one moment and try to play a
good move for a change after after this
really shaky way of converting this
disadvantage how do I win this he
actually look to be two would be great I
go to see three kings III which age for
Bishop you one probably yeah I cannot
take our sim he when he played he didn't
play well that he played quickly
relatively a relatively speaking at
least
who be too should decide right King g3
rook ghs this threat that move I
overlooked totally check but it's also
not working right check white resins guy
was already played this badly I mean
giving back the exchange was fine but
this was a bit to be too relaxed I mean
the computer gives minus 3 and
everything that's cool but it felt a bit
it felt a bit check I don't know child a
bit shaky all that yeah Fuki 8 also was
good okay I was winning all along it's
minus 4 here but Chad it felt like it
held like bad play here I can go i was
thinking what would she ate but then he
has ruger g5 actually I know he doesn't
have that ok so Luke g8 should win
rookie I can still give the check check
check and f2 will promote so that that
should then this should also win their
route back and then I'm I'm getting
getting forward yeah it was a bit that
wasn't really well played check yeah an
important point is in the opening for
any 45 player that here 94 is a good
response it is not terrible for white
sometimes openings opening menu would
say this is totally terrible and that's
not the case but it's just not very
promising take stakes and here if you go
Bishop d3 things I still kind of okay
for white this is for example is equal
and there is this funny idea that is a
bit more bit more exciting but also
leading to to equal play and I know it
looks strange but if is always giving me
the piece back but 95 is a straight
straight straight forward leading to a
very bad position
look f 1 enter whatever it's all good a
six bishop h streets probably all good
and yeah I'm winning the exchange it's
just an unplayable line this Bishop b5
movie and this in this particular
position in the game what was still a
bit tricky if we go back the night here
was was very very pesky so I decided to
return the exchange it's probably i
think a good practical decision it's
it's not so easy to play around that
night su one drew create really and yeah
okay i can go back with the bishop and
try to push the pawns or whatever but i
think Luke be eight is good it also
forces the issue if you mean you cannot
if we if we play like that for example
here but the pressure here he is forced
to take chatham we get the the game
position essentially and this was a
pretty pretty easy win even though I
made it a bit difficult I think okay
well thanks for watching